[Music]
speaking of a brave new world
of content and the way in which we
consume things
uh i have to ask you about uh
zack snyder's justice league it's
basically out there that martian
manhunter was always meant to be a part
of zack snyder's original cut it was
always rumored that
your character in the first two zack
snyder's superman films was meant to be
martian manhunter
can we put those things together i think
you know we could put the rumor
to bed yes i'm uh i am the martian
manager
yeah so i am eternally grateful to zach
uh for seeing it through you know came
about in a very circuitous
way right you know the fans demanded uh
that his vision
be given a a fair hearing
fair viewing if you will and so uh he
actually tagged me on a post it was an
instagram post where he showed the the
canisters
of the of the cut of night or cut
and uh and so it's complete
when exactly it comes out i don't know
i've heard march
uh i don't know when in march uh or even
if it will be in march but that said
you know i'm over the moon about it and
to be in all honesty
uh i had never heard of martian
manhunter
until until these uh until zach
you know brought him to to light and of
course a lot of fans
did know about martian manhunter but i
tell you it's uh
he's a founder of the justice league a
co-founder
um a very powerful uh figure
and it's it's gonna be great to be up
there with batman and superman and my my
pals
so yeah i'm uh once again like a kid of
the candy store
i wanna go through the timeline a little
bit because from what i've read in past
interviews
uh you were basically zack snyder
brought you in
initially for the role in man of steel
and it was i think he made it there's
some comment about how he loved your
voice
um and uh at that point
was it just you're just playing you're
just playing the general you're going to
have some great lines you're going to
get to face off against superman
uh and maybe we'll see you next time
well at that time that's what i thought
you know i thought that it was going to
be a one and done
uh situation you know i was playing uh
calvin swanwick right you know
i knew it was a great part but you know
this is this is an interesting
uh to go back a little bit further liz
when i
i was with the big agency and
i was on a television show and then the
show got you know canceled or what have
you
uh interestingly that show was dollhouse
and so it got canceled and that and my
agency kicked me to the curb and i'm
sort of sit
sitting around like oh man well you know
that's a fine how do you do
after 10 years or whatever and um it's
like and then i saw on the television
that they were going to be rebooting
the superman franchise right oh man i've
always loved superman has been my
favorite hero all the time i would i
would do anything to be
that yeah you know i didn't even think
it was
a couple weeks later the phone rings and
my age and my new agent is like
okay man they they want you uh in this
movie the superman thing
that's like get out of town yeah come on
who are your kid he's like no man they
they really want you
they know they want you in the movie
they aren't sure what part but they want
you to do
you know some testing with potential
superman and
loises and so forth and they're going to
do a a a kind of shoot
like oh yeah i'll do it and so uh
you know technically speaking i think i
was maybe the first actor cass did it
but
obviously it's not the swanwick movie
it's superman
but that said i was over
the moon and i walked out i remember
seeing henry cavill
in the suit and he was actually wearing
christopher reeves original suit
and he had this huge fan you know and he
had the cape
because they wanted the fan to blow the
cape and i was like
man this is uh this i can't top this
this
will there will never be anything
that i could reasonably expect that's
going to be better than this
and i'll be damned if zack snyder didn't
uh didn't top it
you know by marching band under so yeah
it's
it it was um great it was a real
boom to my ego at the time because like
i said i just been
released you know from this thing and uh
and this
allowed me really to get back in the
game
in a very big way and i was uh happy
about that man of steel
you had no idea no were there any hints
were you given any hints or any
suggestions in
batman vs superman in the making of that
film
no okay when zack snyder was developing
his justice league
that's when it was like by the way uh
your character is actually martial
manhunter i never saw the script i
didn't get a chance
to to read the script because they keep
all of those things they were still
being developed
and they keep all of that under lock and
key so you know i had already done
the two and i was on the blacklist at
the time and they had to agree
you know for the scheduling what went on
that had been cleared everything was
gone
i went to the premiere with my wife of
batman superman
and my uh and my sister-in-law
and so it was uh really i think they
were going to say something when i got
to london
to shoot that that was you know the kind
of hidden thing but they
tried to keep all of that information
[Music]
out of the public sphere for as long as
possible until it's all signed off on
and that
so uh so yeah i i was in the dark
until uh until rather late you know
frankly you know zack snyder posted uh
you know basically concept art you know
revealing that martial manhunter was
always going to be a part of it
and recently and he i think the note
that came with it was that he wasn't
able to get basically basically like he
had everything except
you in the can uh so you appear
so was it over the last few months that
you got that footage in the can
yes uh you know this is a brave new
world as we talk about
but uh but yes you know so
i was on a green screen basically so you
can actually film things in a way
where you don't have to uh
you know endanger people but i did shoot
yeah with with zach and his team
back i think in august or something like
that we did a small
little thing would it have maybe been
october yes
it was i'm sorry it was yes it was it
was yes
um yes in terms of that shooting
experience well
you know you know you're you're just
against a green screen i guess so it's
not
maybe as you know physical physical as
it could be
uh but how was that experience well
uh it was it was
it was great you know i mean that is to
say it's an experience you know whenever
you're doing these things i was in the
matrix
two and three as well and you're acting
on the green screen so none of you know
that's not really a change
to be like there's all kinds of stuff
that they add later
uh and you have to just do what it is
that you're going to be doing
and so that's yeah that's how it went it
was uh
uh you know
uh what what it is we do
[Music]
yeah no of course i can't say too much
about it
of course i mean um you know
before before we move on from martian
manhunter uh i do i he's a character i
really enjoy just because i think he has
such a fascinating backstory from the
comics
you know do you have your take on him do
you have like your kind of perspective
on who he is as a character as a founder
of the justice league obviously that is
is
you know he's a good person he's a
heroic figure he's
uh you know not a bad
man like he's not trying to he's trying
to actually make the world
better so you know again i think uh
anybody in
in that league is um
is already sort of determined you know
to be
virtuous and i think i think he's a very
virtuous character as this is
i didn't know much about him i did i did
some research later
uh you know to just sort of shore up my
knowledge about who is
who this guy was but um
but yeah you know i i think a lot of it
is going to be in the hands of zack
and uh and in the context of
what it was that was shot you know in
london
uh i guess a few years back now